i think it's time to chat about lizzo
hey everyone i'm abby sharp and welcome
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Applause]
today's video is sponsored by buildbarb
and we will be exploring the public's
reaction to lizzo's recent
detox tick tocks and discuss this in the
context of the culture of celebrity
diets
now before we get into it let's talk
about my sponsor buildbar
i get asked a lot of questions about
protein bars and if there's one that i
recommend
to help bump up the satiety factor in a
meal or a snack
and honestly i get sent a ton of them
as part of my job and i think that most
of them taste
a lot like chalk so i was super excited
and quite frankly quite surprised when i
tried
a build bar for the first time and
judging by everyone's comments in some
of my other videos
it's obvious that they are fan favorite
with a lot of you too
but i like them because they're a
convenient source of protein if you want
your meal or snack to take you a little
bit further
and honestly they taste like a chocolate
bar
it's like a marshmallowy nuggety texture
that is honestly
so good i mean some people in the
comments described it kind of like a
milky way bar
but with protein and yeah i would agree
with that
so today's little snacky snack flavor is
peanut butter brownie so this one has
19 grams of protein let's have a little
tasty
[Music]
so it is a lower sugar bar which some of
you
may be looking for so if i was to have
this as like a post-workout snack
i would probably pair it with some fruit
or oatmeal
toast or sweet potato to help aid in
recovery
there's clearly a lot of flavors that i
need to work through and i'm really
excited to
go through them with all of you so if
you want to try them out yourself
check out the link in my bio and use the
promo code abbiesharp20
to get 20 off also you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
sensitive to weight loss discussion
we will also be discussing the
intersectionality of race and diet
as well as fat phobia so i do ask that
we keep the comments
kind and supportive and of course don't
forget to subscribe
this channel and ring that little bell
so that you never miss out on a video
all right to kick this video off i want
to first discuss
lizzo in the context of the body
positive movement
so you can also check out my recent
video on body positivity and where
i fit into this movement as a white thin
woman
right here now it's clear that as
a confident fat woman of color lizzo has
been branded as the poster child
of the body positive movement since the
beginning of her career
but as evidenced by a lot of her recent
interviews on the subject
it wasn't an identity that she
necessarily sought out
herself society saw a woman
who they felt was so unapologetically
brave for just being who she was that
her body became one of the most
memorable parts about
her but if most progressive folks today
would find it offensive to praise a
woman for her
whiteness blonde hair or large breasts
and tiny waist
why do we think it's woke to praise a
fat black woman for the body that she
just naturally inhabits too
because spoiler alert friends it's not
in fact in an interview with david
letterman lizzo said
i'm sick of being an activist just
because i'm fat and black
i want to be an activist because i'm
intelligent
care about issues and because my music
is good
so here we have a black fat woman who
has been put on a pedestal by the body
positive community despite her stating
numerous times that she never consented
to that responsibility or role
rather it was assigned to her because of
the size and color of her body
now it's important to remind everyone
that racism and fatphobia
are inextricably linked both
historically and today
and part of the reason for lizzo's
perceived role in the beaupo movement
is because of this intersectionality now
lizzo has also criticized the
commercialization of the body positive
movement
for taking it away from its original
benefactors
that is for example larger body people
of color
as i discussed in my video here having
said that her message has always been
for all people to love themselves at all
sizes
so similar to the discussions i had in
my video on body positivity
where i asked some larger bodied and
bipoc women
if they identified with the term body
positive
most of them actually felt it was not
meant for them
most felt the need to use other language
like
body neutrality body kindness or
self-love
and i came to the same conclusion for
myself so whether lizzo wanted to be the
poster child of body positivity or not
and whether she even identifies with the
term or not
with upbeat tracks and empowering lyrics
like body vicious mind your business
in fitness and thick thighs save lives
in tempo
just to name a few there has always been
a public perception
that lizzo is comfortable in her own
skin
and rightfully so but it's unfortunate
that i am even bringing this
up because this wouldn't even be a thing
if someone like j lo said it in a song
but anyways we move on
so lizza was the publicly appointed bopo
queen
but a lot of fans clapped back hard
when she posted this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh dear so to recap
lizzo posted a what i eat in a day
following jj
smith's 10-day smoothie detox
in it she shared a quick disclaimer
stating that she was practicing
safe detox methods with a nutritionist
and to not try it without any research
now the video included a variety of
completely
bogus wellness products like a green
smoothie detox supplements
beauty water a superfood shake
alkaline water an herbal bath cucumbers
and apple cider vinegar
and some strange detox foot pads
no clue what that was about no way
now the next series of clips features a
variety of before and after images of
her body
while the narration talks about doing
this to
reset her stomach she also posted a
follow-up video after getting some
initial backlash
arguing that the detox was not about
weight loss
but rather that she was trying to
reverse some of the digestive issues
that she faced in the fall
now before we go any further i feel
i need to kind of take this down
even though i'm sure most abby's kitchen
subbies know exactly
what i'm going to say so yeah
i'm going to try to be succinct here and
also please note that any sass that i do
have going on
is not directed at lizzo but rather
at this crap itself now first of all
i went through jj's book the 10 day
green smoothie cleanse which
was a pretty sad way to spend my time to
be honest
but this book says right on the cover
that you will lose
15 pounds in 10 days
yikes that right there folks should be
your first
red flag considering that most
legitimate nutrition professionals would
advise against losing more than
one to two pounds a week we're already
off to
a pretty rough start now the book goes
on to suggest that traditional diets
don't ever work because they don't
address the
toxic waste in your body now
jj then suggests that you need to first
rid your body of toxins to ensure that
you can metabolize food
without leaving excess waste and it's
that waste
that apparently causes weight gain oh
boy
folks there is zero evidence that
getting rid of
any waste aka going to the bathroom
will speed up or change our metabolism
that is just actual bs
if you do lose weight from detoxing over
a few days
it's because you're either peeing
pooping or sweating more
all of which is only offloading excess
water
and not actual fat the diet then goes on
to suggest
60 ounces of green juice each day
plus some low calorie veggies and high
protein snacks
a ton of water including a flavored
beauty variety
and of course a colon cleanse i guess
lizzo left that little detail out of her
post and
honestly i am glad she did
because we do not need to see an uptick
in google searches for colonic clinics
right now folks i know there's a lot of
people who
love their colon hydrotherapy but as i
discussed in my video
right here medical professionals often
warn
that colonics may increase the risk for
nutrient deficiencies
infection and gi disturbances
in fact one meta-analysis found that it
actually
exacerbated ibs symptoms causing
abdominal pain
cramping electrolyte imbalances and even
renal failure considering that lizzo
cited her stomach
being effed up as the rationale for the
protocol in the first place
i am definitely hoping she completely
skipped this step the book also
recommends cleansing your liver with a
variety of teas
apple cider vinegar and herbs all of
which we saw lizzo consume in her video
now i've talked about apple cider
vinegar ad nauseam here
and while some small studies have linked
its regular consumption to
very modest weight loss it's believed
that this is
largely because it can cause a reduction
in appetite from mild
nausea other research on its benefits
for blood sugar regulation
and heart health have been largely done
on animal models
or super small sample sizes and none of
it proves that it helps to
detox your liver likewise the
supplements and teas that jj suggests
like milk thistle may show some small
benefits for improving
blood cholesterol or insulin resistance
in some
super small tiny studies but they have
shown
no benefit for detoxing your liver
as for alkaline water its main detox
claims rest on the fact that it has
a higher ph than regular water but
experts suggest that
while you can maybe manipulate the water
in a petri dish to keep it at a higher
ph
you will have no such luck in the
stomach
where the ph is naturally resting
between 1.5 and
3.5 in other words this is just
overpriced h2o as for the foot pads
this probably is the strangest and
shadiest part of the whole thing
uh but jj's book suggests that they can
help to draw
toxins out of the body while you sleep
the reality is
toxin eliminating foot treatments like
ionic foot baths
have been thoroughly debunked by the
medical community
it's literally a pretty common snake oil
scam
the only reason you would see any color
changes that may be used as
evidence of toxins leaving the body is
because of some
natural chemical reactions with various
salts and ions
so to sum it up obviously
this detox is not evidence-based and
potentially
dangerous considering you're supposed to
do this
routine for 10 whole days
so if you want real safe detox methods
just eat some food drink some water go
for a walk
and then proceed to sweat piss crap and
breathe out the toxins
because safe detoxing is what your body
is naturally designed
to do hard stuff
anyways i'm getting riled up on this
detox bs but
that is not what this video is about now
back to the public's reaction
to put it succinctly lizzo's fans
were not impressed they were attacking
her for promoting diet culture
and seemingly contradicting everything
they believed
that she stood for now i have to be
totally honest when these videos came
out
i got about a million and one dms about
them
filled with genuine concern that this
body positive queen
was transitioning to the dark side of
diet culture
and i admit i was really taken aback by
the video series myself
but it was not because i thought lizzo
was letting down the fat community
or denouncing her vow of self-love
as i've said a million times in a
million different videos
i believe in body autonomy and you're
not a failure at loving yourself
if you want to lose weight i'm also not
even going to debate whether or not
lizzo's before and after shots were
proof that she was doing the cleanse for
weight loss rather than for
digestion and health honestly these days
the lines are so blurred between one's
concern
around reducing like bloating versus
reducing fat
and that is all a moot point anyway
i strongly believe that lizzo can do
whatever the hell she wants with her
body
and i will support her because she's
smart
beautiful and a truly talented artist
plus truth hurts will forever go down as
one of my all-time
favorite songs period we just keep it
pushing like
but we shouldn't be upset at lizzo for
wanting to do a detox
or lose weight we should be upset with
diet culture
itself and the system that allows
pseudoscience and nutrition
misinformation
to occupy every communication stream we
access
i believe strongly and i always have
said this
that all public personalities
influencers
and celebrities possess incredible
responsibility
to vet the claims that they make about
the things that they share
publicly even if it's prefaced by this
is just what i'm doing
do your own research we all know that a
lot of
young impressionable fans lack the
critical thinking skills to do
anything but emulate their idols so i
feel at least
that it's fair to be disappointed that
lizza would promote a protocol
with no evidence to back it up that in
fact could be
really devastating in the wrong hands i
am
also annoyed that she partnered with a
nutritionist j.j smith whose
education includes a certificate from
the institute of holistic healing
a course that i could find no legitimate
information about
online and who exclusively promotes
sensationalized protocols
like the seven day apple cider vinegar
cleanse
in addition to the smoothie one that
lizzo did but
lizzo is not a superhuman she is
susceptible to
snake oil salespeople and
sensationalized
wellness promises just like the rest of
us
in fact in a follow-up post lizzo said
that
i spent so much time in this body and i
am no different than you
still struggling to find balance still
trying to mend my relationship with food
with my anxiety my back fat if i have
any advice
it's to eat drink move rest your job is
to grow
your job is to figure it out along the
way regardless of what i
or any other so-called expert says
in other words she's still on her own
journey
and if you or i can be roped in by a
promise to
reset our digestion or reverse the harm
done through
lifestyle choices why the hell can't she
so i actually have a lot of empathy for
lizzo because we really can't expect her
or anyone else to know that this is
all total bunk the other disparity that
we need to acknowledge when it comes to
lizzo's detox experience
is that we don't seem to see the same
level of scrutiny towards
white larger bodied female celebrities
who go on journeys to lose weight
and we don't see people immediately
idolize them as
bopo heroes even when they rock their
confidence and self-love too
adele rebel wilson melissa mccarthy
kelly osborne jessica simpson just to
name a few
all very publicly shrank their bodies
and while fans were tearing down lizzo
for allegedly breaking her fat positive
vow
these women were largely praised adele
captioned her post-weight loss photo
with the caption
i used to cry but now i sweat only to
get spammed with all the heart and fire
emojis
and comments about her beauty and rebel
wilson
thanked followers for all the love on
her year of health journey
with this picture and fans commented
back with hearts
clapping emojis and excitement that she
was pursuing her goals
like lizzo all of these women are
beautiful
talented and at least at some point
larger bodied yet when lizzo goes on a
detox
whether or not said diet was to change
her body or her health
she's land-based then adele on the other
hand who has been
associated with body positive movement
as well can follow an
equally bogus set of rules aka the cert
food diet
and is celebrated for her commitment to
good health
now i acknowledge that the disparity in
a lot of cases may come down to the fact
that lizzo
was so strongly aligned with the bopo
movement
but she did nothing differently from
these other celebrities
other than just be herself to be
publicly assigned that role
to dive a little bit deeper into these
issues i brought on a body image coach
and content creator danny of i'm a pound
cake
thanks for joining me danny hi thank you
for having me
so why do you think the public's
reaction to lizzo's
detox was so different from the public's
reaction to other larger bodied white
celebrities like
rubble wilson and adele well i think a
lot of it has to do with that lizzo is
black right
and a lot of the media representation
that we've seen of that black women
um has been controlled uh by the media
and lizzo living her her life and in a
way that
um people are not used to was triggering
because she is definitely a fat black
woman and
we even though there's a lot of fat
phobia and we
we experience that in our society based
on all different
sizes when that is coupled with
blackness there's a layer
uh that gets confusing for people and
then we see
uh this racial undertone comes out and
in the way that we treat larger bodies
okay and
and and what do you think about lizzo
being painted as like the poster child
of the body positive movement i think
it's unfair i think there's a lot of
things that happen right i think that
lizzo also participated um
in kind of being the poster child um but
also
uh this we always do this to black women
also right like we make black women our
martyrs we make black women the
prototype of the
prototype of the thing but we don't give
them the agency that they're asking for
we don't give them
the chance to make public mistakes or
live their lives in ways that we allow
white women of any size to live their
life right and
we never see any backlash
to white women in the same way that we
see it to black
uh black women and we think uh black
women who are larger who are special
like fat black women we expect for them
to be our mammy that trope
was created by white uh westerners
um who created this idea that uh fat
black women are our mothers they're
supposed to nurture
uh this entire uh revolution
any revolution right and be our
caretakers
um which is unfair it's rooted in racism
um it's a problem and it's something
that i think people in the body
positivity movement
should call out and that's a little bit
of my issue with this movement right
we we only talk about bodies from a lens
of size and eating disorders
and we never get down to race and then
the ways that
fat black bodies have been positioned in
society
especially when they have been femme a
lot of the racist images
of fat black women are not talked about
in the body positivity
movement and so it's hard for people to
understand
um what they're doing to lizzo i think
people
know what they're doing but i don't
think people understand how to explain
what is happening
okay so why and how is race an important
part of the body positive movement
i think it's really important that
people who are part of this movement
um see fat black people as people who
are treated differently not just because
of size
but also because of race um because
we do not get to think of our bodies as
just the way up about the way that
we don't get to think of our bodies as a
function right and what they can do for
us
it's also a different experience when i
walk in the store
in this body and how people may follow
me because i live in this body
and that's also a body positivity issue
the death of brianna taylor is a body
positive issue the the death of george
floyd is a body positive
issue um because we don't get to
separate our size
um from the way that we exist in this
world due to our race
wow that's so beautiful and just
so enlightening for i'm sure everyone
who's watching so
thank you so much for sharing that i
really appreciate your time
um and i hope you have a fantastic new
year
thank you have a good day so you can
check out where to find danny in the
description below
now a few final thoughts on lizzo's role
in the body positive space
first of all a lot of you may be
wondering if lizzo's
detox tick tock means that she should
lose her crown as
queen of the bopo movement well
much like what i discussed in my video
on cassie from blog lattes here
lizzo actually never signed up for the
gig
she just sought out to share her musical
talent with the world
and give some amazing live and recorded
performances
and it just so happens that she's doing
it while living
in a fat black body that should not be
her defining feature
and the fact that it is even by her
biggest fans
is evidence of a lot of underlying
racism and fat phobia
in our society so posting those tick
tocks does not make lizzo
antibody positive and we shouldn't be
mad at lizzo
her desire to lose weight or get healthy
whatever her motivation is
is no less valid than a white woman's
desire or goal
also tearing women down for being at
different points in their body positive
journey
is not helping the problem it doesn't
change the societal pressures
of our aesthetic driven culture it just
shames women
for being too powerless to overcome them
so robbing lizzo of the same grace and
liberties that we afford
other larger bodied women is a problem
and it diverts the attention away from
what we should be really working towards
as a society
and that is dismantling diet culture
debunking nutrition misinformation
and examining our own internal biases
rather than
other people's individual choices and on
that note
that is all that i have for today thank
you again to bill barr for sponsoring
this video
and for danny for her amazing insight if
you like this video
don't forget to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some of
your thoughts on the lisso detox
fiasco subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you